Bobby's gone through a few rough periods
oh like uh uh you know with drugs and
alcohol and all that kind of stuff so
and uh just everything else involved I
mean that's the beautiful roller coaster
of who he is and a lot of great
comedians seem to be that way so I
wonder what the connection there is you
think some level of crazy is required
for comedy yeah like at some point yes
on a scale of one to ten how much crazy
do you have
uh in some ways a 10 uh and in other
ways that I think uh
in other ways sort of functionally I'm
like a two or a three because uh I don't
know Steve from Canada and I'm yeah I I
you know I try to just keep things very
even keeled my parents are Italian
they're from Italy and uh you know
they're very they grew up during World
War II and they're very you know uh
simple outlook on things they're complex
incredible classy people who are
very simple when it comes to a lot of
stuff and and uh I I think just being a
sort of a at heart kind of a timid
Canadian coming out here years ago as a
kid uh it was uh all I could do to just
keep everything super normal and then I
sort of was able to settle into that as
a lifestyle but you love the idea of
being an actor like who uh you mentioned
John Candy and uh planes planes and
Automobiles yeah it's one of my favorite
movies just as one of yours what do you
think that makes that movie work what
what do you what
um and when you when you talk about
enjoying that movie do you enjoy just
the raw comedy or do you enjoy like the
friendship and and the love that's there
even though on the surface
it doesn't make any sense that there
should be a friendship there I mean
that's such an important element to that
film but uh you know as a kid I just
love the comedy and then I it's been a
nostalgic favorite of mine like it's my
favorite movie
uh but it's also uh it's just legit my
favorite movie because as you get older
and you start watching it you realize
it's what it's what John Hughes is the
filmmaker and what John Candy
particularly and but also Steve Martin
are doing in the film that makes it such
a work of art which is
loneliness is there in every moment of
that film and John Candy is he embodies
Del Griffith his character in the film
he he Del Griffith is a lonely guy and
John Candy but but Del Griffith is also
a very friendly guy and a shower curtain
ring salesman and knows everybody in the
Midwest and runs around to motels and
has meaningful conversations with the
guy evening Gus you know whoever he's
talking to
um uh but there's loneliness there all
the time and uh you know this is a
character these the film is filled with
loneliness and it's not until you know
the second last scene when he's at the
train station
you know Dell what are you doing here
you thought I thought you were going
home what are you doing here
um that's a very good Neil Neil Page
from the movie thank you uh that's when
you realize how lonely
cheers that's when you realize how
lonely he is and I think that's the
element from the film that
I mean look you know nowadays I I feel
like I've been saying this for a long
time but John Candy would have won an
Academy Award hands down for that film
it's just they didn't do that with
comedies back then yeah until the year
after that movie came out with Fish
Called Wanda yeah and then it's I mean
it's still Communists don't get
respected enough probably Williams he
got I guess he got an Oscar for good
Goodwill Hunting
um Jim Carrey did he ever get an Oscar I
don't know I don't believe so no yeah
they don't get
you don't but that's not even if he did
you wouldn't be for comedies
it's just I mean there's some things
that are
um
playing streams and honor maybe would
you even put that as a com I guess it's
a comedy yeah I mean there's a there is
a loneliness and depth that permeates
the whole movie yeah that ultimately and
it's a happy ending which is hard to
kinda it's a happy ending only because
in the last moment of the movie
John Candy puts on a brave face
even when he's got no one and he's there
seeing Neil Page's entire family on
Thanksgiving and he forces a smile which
is the last literally the last frame of
the movie and I've said before if you're
not reduced to just a solving pile of
meat uh at the end of the movie then you
are not human
um yeah it's it's
it is a happy ending it's a happy ending
even though it's a it's a sad so much
character loneliness in the world I was
just in Vegas
I went to a diner at like 4 a.m 5 A.M
and there's the waitresses empty as a
waitress that was the sweetest kindest
human being kept calling me sweetheart
and all that kind of stuff hun
and then after I ate she sat down and
just talked to me a little bit you know
it's because there's nobody nobody there
and it was just there's so much sadness
in her eyes I don't know but also so
much love like that sweetheart
that I mean it reminded me kind of um
of of the John Candy performance because
at first because I was like uh reading a
pretty dark uh
uh book about Hitler uh so I was a
little bit frustrated that she kept
talking to me because it was like uh it
was it was almost like uh the same way
that John Candy is it's annoying a
little bit right but then very quickly I
opened up to like oh this is
there's a kind human being and there's
like that human connection superseded
everything else and I don't know it was
just beautiful and I think John Candy
captures that
really well which is like the connection
with other human beings sometimes
we pull away from that because we have a
busy life full of stuff to do uh as
um Steve Martin's character and
characterize he's like a marketing exec
or something like that but if you just
pause and notice others you can you can
really discover Beautiful People totally
totally everyone's got well I mean
everyone's got their their story and you
know
candy as a person I've never met the man
uh but um he's the kind of guy that you
know he could he could just walk up to
back in the day I would imagine he could
walk up to just about any house at least
in Canada knock on the door and you'd
invite him in for dinner you know what I
mean so yeah it's a it's a bit that you
know as you're talking about you know
putting a book down and talking to
someone for a while even though you'd
really like to read your book it's it's
like it's that sort of thing that
Candy's character in the movie sort of
does that like Johnny Appleseed just can
you realize he's just going around
making people smile you know and and
Neil Page is hanging with this guy so
frustrated he's just a he's so
exhausting in his big underwear in the
sink at the hotel and everything and by
the end of it he loves this guy you know
so uh it's a good and a bad thing that
you have didn't take that waitress with
you on a trip maybe road trip up to Reno
oh oh she's she's actually she's out
shopping right now we've been having uh
sex multiple times a day ever since oh
that's nice that's lovely I think I'm
sure she's married and and happily and
has many grandchildren okay
uh and and plus that movie's on
Thanksgiving I think right yeah
Thanksgiving so like Thanksgiving just
embodies that forget about the the
busyness and the whatever the career
you're chasing in life and just take a
pause and appreciate the people you lost
people with your family yeah